[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce lundi 3 avril la
colère des surveillants pénitentiaires
de la prison de bois d'arcy à l'appel du
syndicat force ouvrière plusieurs
dizaines d'entre eux ont bloqué l'accès
à la prison ce matin
il dénonce une montée de la violence au
sein de l'établissement et le manque de
moyens humains 200 km à travers les
routes départementales en cinq jours les
participants du premier cyclo défi
yvelinois ont pris le départ ce matin
devant le vélodrome nationale objectif
rambouillet pour la première étape
enfin une bonne idée dans ce journal en
pleines vacances scolaires et alors que
le beau temps s'installe sur la région
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines propose un grand nombre
d'activités et notamment c'est une
nouveauté 2010 est du paint ball ils
étaient donc une vingtaine de
surveillants ce matin à bloquer le
centre pénitentiaire de bois d'arcy une
action lancée par le syndicat fo suite à
plusieurs agressions et une montée de
violence survenus ces derniers jours
contre des gardiens de la paix une
situation compliquée pour ces
manifestants le représentant fo à bois
d'arcy willis avait alerté les autorités
publiques sur la situation
il était au micro ce matin de nicolas
d'andry écoutez le on se demande c'est
avoir de l'effectif conséquent il faut
savoir que
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui quasiment toutes
les établissements de la région
parisienne sont à 200 % du taux
d'occupation et malheureusement face à
cette montée en puissance de la
population carcérale n'avons pas le
nombre de surveillants conséquent donc
il est difficile pour un surveillant de
faire de mener à bien ses missions dans
ces conditions difficiles dans un
premier temps nous ce qu'on demande à
force ouvrière c'est des établissements
spécialisés pour des détenus
notamment pour les détenus radicaliser
donc ces détenus à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
sont en détention normale avec le reste
de la population pénale et c'est très
compliqué à versailles une autre
manifestation dans l'actualité locale
nous vous en parlions déjà au mois de
février l'élevage de chevaux d'estelle
est rare située à d'avron est en danger
l'éleveuse est désormais expulsé du
terrain qu'elle occupe avec ses 40
chevaux et poneys de loisirs ces
candidatures pour acquérir un autre
terrain n'ont pas été retenus par
l'autorité compétente et pour alerter
sur sa situation
une marche de soutien était organisée ce
vendredi pour faire le tour des
administrations départementales écouter
sur ce sujet et stand est rare elle
était au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude ceux qui siègent au comité
technique de la safer il y en a
quelques-uns qui sont dans le parcours
qu'on a tracé qu'il nous donne un peu
leur sentiment concernant ma candidature
est pourquoi elle n'a pas été retenue
savoir si eux mêmes ils ont eu bien tous
les tenants et les aboutissants
justement de cette candidature est un
peu l'urgence de la situation il faut
absolument qu'on trouve une solution est
hélas c'est un peu la marche de la
dernière chance cela dit si on n'arrive
pas à trouver des contacts ou des
rendez-vous qui peuvent déboucher sur
quelque chose c'est bien l'idée ça sera
après d'aller à paris en politique
à trois semaines du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle les militants
des onze candidats sont mobilisés et
notamment ceux des plus petits candidats
à l'instar des soutiens de jacques
cheminade plusieurs d'entre eux étaient
récemment devant la gare de versailles
chantiers pour distribuer des tracts et
échanger avec les voyageurs un reportage
de nicolas landry
pour arrêter les politiques d'austérité
lecture lecture du soir pour appeler
d'été candidat en 2012 campagne
compliquée pour les soutiens de jacques
cheminade dans les yvelines
ils sont confrontés au manque de
popularité de leur candidat selon les
derniers sondages ils ne dépassent pas
la barre des 1% l'an née lui je ne
connais pas et puis bah je n'ai même pas
entendu parler je sais pas du tout donc
je vais juste dire déjà savoir mais je
ne connais pas puisqu'ils viennent m'en
parler et je vais documenté je veux dire
et gérer un peu plus sur sur un site où
je vais voir ce que ce qu'il a à
proposer et à dire quoi jacky minaj elle
est connue depuis pas mal d'années à
travers à travers les médias et c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait qu'un énorme des
bonnes idées mais malheureusement je
pense qu'ils se réveillent un petit peu
trop tard avec tout ce qui se passe
actuellement au sein des médias
concernant pas mal d des candidats autre
difficulté le vote utile de plus en plus
évoquée par les électeurs je vais pas
voter pour monsieur cherche mineurs je
vais essayer de jeter je vous dire
pourquoi parce que j'ai très peur de
dieu du front national concernant le
programme plusieurs mesures économiques
sous le slogan libérez les français de
l'occupation financière au lieu
d'utiliser l'argent des gens et l'argent
de l'état pour sauver les banques
on veut séparer la partie banque
d'affaires pour la laisser assumer ses
dettes tout seul sans la renflouer et
que l'état retrouve le moyen de
contrôler que l'état retrouve le
contrôle sur sa monnaie pour financer
les politiques de développement en 2012
jacques cheminade avait recueilli près
de 0 23% des suffrages dans les yvelines
c'est un ouf de soulagement pour de
nombreuses yvelinois les élus du
département se sont prononcé il ya
quelques jours sur le taux de la taxe
foncière sur les propriétés bâties et
après une hausse record de 66 % l'an
passé les élus ont voté cette année pour
un maintien du taux actuel à 12,58 % le
département des yvelines conservancy
l'une des taxes foncières les plus
basses de france à noter aussi durant
cette séance la signature d'un protocole
d'accord pour l'implantation du nouveau
centre d'entraînement du psg à poissy
club de la capitale devrait rendre ce
déménagement effectif pour l'équipe
masculine à l'horizon de la saison
2019-2020 à saint quentin en yvelines le
départ du premier cyclo défi du
département a été donné ce matin devant
le vélodrome national direction
rambouillet sous l'égide de
l'association solidarité handicap france
cameroun 13 collégiens issus des
quartiers prioritaires vont parcourir
jusqu'à vendredi environ 200 kilomètres
sur les routes du département
objectif les aider à prendre confiance
en eux et leur faire découvrir une autre
facette de leur territoire l'image et
des jeunes des quartiers prioritaires
est négative
pourtant là dedans il ya certains qui
sont bons ou même ceux qui sont pas bons
on peut aller chercher et améliorer donc
il ya ce leadership la travailler le
développement perdent leur développement
personnel et puis l'étape aussi qui m'a
beaucoup séduit c'est de les sortir de
leur environnement quotidien
allez découvrir les départements qui est
le leur s'en approprier nouvelle job
academy pour la banque populaire val de
france l'entreprise lance sa deuxième
promotion avec la fondation agir contre
l'exclusion
une vingtaine d'employés a accepté
d'accompagner des demandeurs d'emploi la
première rencontre s'est tenue vendredi
dernier dans les locaux de l'entreprise
pendant quatre mois au total les binômes
vont se rencontrer tous les quinze jours
écoutez d'ailleurs le témoignage d'un
filleul et d'une marraine il était au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
selligent qui ont qui ont beaucoup
d'expérience il peut vous conseiller
pour pour se positionner sur sur une
offre d'emploi ou bien aussi
ou bien aussi nous aider à modifier un
peu des cv pour ma part c'est une très
bonne initiative
j'ai la chance d'être dans une
entreprise la banque populaire depuis 22
ans et donc je ne me suis jamais trouvés
en situation de chômage et donc il me
semble important de faire profiter mon
expérience des personnes qui sont en
situation difficile
je vous le disais en titre c'est un bon
moyen de profiter du soleil actuelle en
pleines vacances scolaires l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
organisée ce week-end ses premières
journées portes ouvertes l'occasion
aussi de tester une nouvelle activité
sur l'île le paint ball
retour sur cet événement avec un
reportage de nicolas landry et camille
lambert des enfants qui font la guerre
ou presque il ne risque pas grand chose
si ce n'est une balle de peinture en
paint ball deux équipes s'affrontent sur
un terrain et pour survivre il ne faut
pas se faire toucher près d 1 ab jeudi
les îles leur tire dessus
on en a tué quatre mon frère 2 et a
pressé on a gagné on est venu faire
cette activité en famille à passer un
bon moment
les enfants aiment un peu les sports un
peu extrêmes donc on en profite
une activité proposée exceptionnellement
sur l'île de loisirs pour ces journées
portes ouvertes les visiteurs ont pu se
lancer d'autres défis comme le football
ou l'équitation
un événement pour lancer la saison avec
l'arrivée des beaux jours
il ya encore trop de personnes qui ne
connaissent pas ce havre de paix cela
ouvre des espaces verts donc voilà c'est
ça l'objectif principal c'est de faire
découvrir l'île de loisirs et toutes les
activités qui s'y
pratique le panel d'activités est très
très très complet et pour reprendre la
formule bien connue de 7 à 77 ans mais
bien au-delà
face au succès de ce week end le
paintball devraient être ajoutés au
catalogue d'activités chaque année six à
sept cent mille visiteurs sont
accueillis sur les 620 hectares de l'île
de l'art de la main verte aussi célébré
ce week-end pour sa neuvième édition
esprit jardin de versailles s'intéresser
à cette année au jardin urbain plus de
80 stands étaient se tenait sur le
parvis de la cathédrale saint louis ix
et pour la deuxième année consécutive le
potager du roi étaient en accès libre le
temps d'un week-end
visite guidée avec nicolas landry et
mélanie poké il y a plus de 300 ans
louis xiv et cultiver ses fruits et
légumes préférés comme les fraises ou
les asperges au potager du roi on
cultive aujourd'hui près de 800 variétés
en trouvant si j'ose dire un écosystème
en nous trouvant un espace dans laquelle
nous trouvons nous cherchons un
équilibre entre produire et prélevées
entre produire et
et rendre un espace beau on fait aussi
bien plus que ça parce que les deux
parce que le potager est une école
depuis la révolution française il y à
eut installé dans ce jardin des écoles
successifs et donc aujourd'hui nous
formons les futurs paysagistes pour le
potager c'était aussi les premières
ouvertures du week-end est la seule
gratuite de l'année on apprécie
l'endroit l'histoire de l'endroit ce
lieu qui était dessinée qui a été depuis
de longues années qui servait de garde
manger là pour un seul monsieur un peu
riches les autres ils crevaient de faim
à on a trouvé ça très beau c'est assez
impressionnant comme lieu c'est vraiment
magnifique
il ya des poulaillers il ya des beaucoup
de pommiers le potager du roi ouvrait
ses portes pour la seconde fois pur
esprit jardin on referme ce journal avec
du sport et du baseball et le début de
saison parfait des cougars de montigny
le bretonneux deux victoires en deux
matches à domicile pour leur retour en
première division lésigny montain ont
dominé les armes de clermont ferrand
miquel et demi d'euros nicolas de landry
et xavier jaglin un début de saison
parfait pour montigny le bretonneux les
cougars promu cette année en 1re
division longtemps porté ce dimanche 2
avril sur latin contre les arvernes de
carnon ferrand le score 6-0 dans le
premier match et 3 2 dans le second
excellente très bonne journée c'était le
but c'était d'entrée de réussir notre
entrée dans ce championnat et on l'a
fait on a fait de très belle façon
on l'a fait avec des lanceurs qui ont
tout donné qui ont fait vraiment le job
sur le monticule
c'est ce que j'attendais c'est ce que
j'attendais aujourd'hui vraiment de
cette journée et voilà ça c'est ça s'est
réalisé ça essayez si c'est génial on
était tous motivés tous dans l'esprit
d'équipé oui c'est tous motivés
on est tous solidaires c'est ce qui a
fait qu'on a qu'on a pu gagner avec ces
deux victoires les cougars de montigny
le bretonneux se retrouve en tête de
première division avec 100% de victoires
les objectif pourrait être revu à la
hausse ses objectifs mais voilà ils sont
ils sont ils sont ce qu'ils sont c'est
allez allez prendre le alley smet se
classer dans le haut de tableau
[Applaudissements]
on a parlé de maintien on a parlé de 5e
6e place je pense qu'aujourd'hui on peut
on peut aller grimper on peut on peut
monter se placer en haut de tableau on
peut aller faire les play-offs
allez comme je dis chatouiller les
grosses écuries les grosses équipes qui
sont là depuis des années on peut le
faire on peut vraiment le faire le
prochain match va arriver vite les
cougars se déplaceront ce dimanche 9
avril sur le terrain de rouen baseball
76 l'équipe qui a soulevé dix titres de
champion de france dans son histoire et
qui a remporté ses deux premiers matches
lors de cette première journée nationale
aux armoiries c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le
journal tous nos reportages sont à
retrouver en replay sur notre site
internet tv fil 78 points comme ou
l'application tv fil 78 bonne soirée à
tous
[Musique]